this is a production of Cornell
University quickly introduction of
myself I'm currently the associate
director of pharma training and
pharmacology and I'm also the co-owner
of Roxbury farm in Kinderhook New York
which is a biodynamic farm in 425 acres
where we do vegetables and pork beef and
lamb and the last four years have been
involved in project in Hurley New York
it's about 1,200 acres of farm lands
class-one silt loam form a sweet corn
conventional sweet corn farm that I was
asked to help transition to organic
practices so most of my task has been to
help them guide them through the process
of the rotation and bringing this land
into ecological practices part of that
is that we're working with the farm
scape ecology program based in Harlem
Ville New York to not just look at soil
data we're working with the soil health
test to monitor soil we're also looking
at water quality and look at ecological
qualities on the lands and we're in our
third year at third year right now to do
this monitoring and mapping and do some
additional research but in the context
of and do I have a clicker I do in the
context really of the farmer training
program that we started which is really
meant to as the niche in the farmer
training program that we have there's a
lot of them around in the Hudson Valley
in New York to see if we can have a farm
and training program that can allow our
students to scale up a little bit
prepared for farm ownership so it's an
entrepreneurial training whereby we
really want to prepare them for farm
ownership and with the ability to be
exposed somewhat to working with
equipment one of the things that I do
with our students is that I really want
to push them a little hard it's a
non-profit we have a very cushy
environment in the sense that we can
make mistakes so I love making mistakes
I've done in all my life and
we're happy to continue doing that while
being paid for it
and so one of the things that we were
really struggling with is that yes we
know how to grow vegetables but can we
grow vegetables in an ecological way and
we all know that the one thing that we
bump up against with organic vegetables
is really that we do a lot of tillage
people who know me know that I like to
work with you know weeding equipment and
keeping my fields clean although I also
have worked very extensively with cover
crops very long ago we adopted an or
dell system is anyone familiar with the
nor Dells
everybody is they are my heroes so we
have been you know alternating on a
vegetable farming Kinderhook with cover
crops one year green manures and then
vegetable crop adopts in the other year
we've actually improved our soil health
that way I know I heard a lot today
about saying that we cannot increase
organic matter with cover crops alone my
question is really how tall were these
cover crops because we have really
brought our organic matter up from about
1.2 1.4 to 2.4 it's not a lot that takes
15 years to get there but one of the
things is is it another farm that I
transition from very intensive
vegetables to organic vegetables is that
we inherit the two farms where with the
excessive amount of phosphorus and
excessive amount of potassium in the
soil so bringing in animal fertilizer
was not an option for us the only way
that we could complement really growing
organic vegetables was by bringing
significant amount of nitrogen into a
system by fixing nitrogen out of the air
and also by doing that we have also
fixed immense amount of carbon out of
the air all right go back to the pro
farmer training I'm pushing them to do
something more innovative so we set like
okay we've looked at all the stuff that
being done with minimum till vegetables
and we're going to try a couple of
things oh I lost the screen oh here we
go
so we do quite a bit of conventional
till vegetables their curriculum is
based on five groups of vegetables of
which some of the groups of the
vegetables in the Brassica the Brassica
is one group lent themselves quite well
for a particular part in the season not
for the early brassicas but definitely
for the later brassicas to be planned
and enrolled and crimped veg or roll on
roll and creams are seen field piece
also the other group that we have are
the legumes lend themselves very well to
be plant a true rolled and cream dry oh
by the way my apologies if anyone
thought of it's going to talk about
mixed species here I'm not talking about
mixed or mixtures here it's pretty
simple debt or rye we really wanted to
address the whole idea about if you are
planting your brassicas in Rye we
already know that we're going to be
having to bring in a lot of nitrogen to
offset the the fact that the Rye is so
high in in carbon so we want to make
sure that we could bring the veg the
vegetable bring in the night if you need
it for the brassicas to grow oh actually
let me tell you one thing I'm all think
I'm not going to really talk much about
the edamame and the snap beans those are
kind of like the easy ones we've been
growing at the farm hub soybeans
truevolt and creme dry for a number of
years we've gotten pretty good at it
pretty good weed control in there so I
think we learned there the snap beans
work equally well we were a little
concerned with the Machine harvesting
we're gonna pick up the rice straw
wasn't an issue at all
what I want to focus on is more on this
one here Washington winter peas also we
tried field piece with bell beans that
did not work I've you know used for many
years a rotation mabye I planned field
peace and bail beans in the spring and I
worked them under and that gives us up
to two hundred pounds of nitrogen to
grow our broccoli cauliflower
and cabbage actually I know that we are
fixing that much because Laurie
Drinkwater had a graduate student go out
and actually find out how much we were
actually fixing and we don't put any
fertilizer down except boron to grow
these crops when we're old and crimp
them they disappear too fast
you actually went to pee stayed around a
little bit longer so we using a crimper
everybody familiar with it but then also
what we do is we were thinking like how
we're gonna kill it all in one shot
well we were thinking about us at the
performance we went around and we said
like well when you just cut it it's in
you know an indeterminate crop so the
problem with that is is that a flowers
at different times so either we're going
to roll it three times and going over it
or we're gonna try to kill it all of one
so we just hooked behind our track that
we hooked to the no-till drill and we
just cut it and the cutting actually
immediately killed it so this is what it
looked like when a good stand of the RC
winter piece and then the other thing we
wanted to resolve it how are you gonna
plant through that we have some funding
we bought this rej planner that Ryan
uses as well and free fill and we got
that's from you and we enjoyed working
with it except that we think that maybe
it is more than what we really need what
we founding is that we really don't need
some of the equipment on that we took
the row cleaners off almost immediately
they made a mess and then also the
Shengo is this cool liquor here this
here is a shank here that they insisted
to have on there we took that off the
ground is pretty soft in a minimum till
system this is not a no-till system by
any means so we took great care in
preparing the seed Beth in the year
before and then really all you need
really to plant into a crop like this
it's really a double disc opener and
then over here is a wavy Coulter if you
have this in the double disc opener you
can use any transplanter to get your
crop in the ground
can see here how that works so here's
after planting this is 26th of June and
then it grew and then you can see the
weeds who are coming in so here we
definitely saw we didn't have enough
biomass to really have good weed control
but there was good growth in it and so
what we ended up doing we went to it
with a little stone rolling cultivator I
had to clean it off after every pass but
otherwise it worked relatively decent
and then we have the crew hand how it
unfortunately I cannot ship how many she
took this is a point seven acre piece
that we handheld and but you know it
it was definitely about between 40 and
50 hours that I remember that we spent
on that that's a lot of hours again you
know cost was not an issue for us this
is a learning experience so it kept
growing and then let me see you can see
there's some weeds going in there but at
this point the canopy starts to close up
you can see the weeds are growing a
little higher now this is really
interesting
I believe I hope this this slides on the
same day they're not the same day you
can see here this is really important
for me this is observation I mean none
of it is what I'm bringing to you as
research this is really like us trying
some things out and throwing some you
know paint at the wall and see what
sticks but this is interesting
irrigated equally the plot we they
decide by side comparison its wilting
and if you look at this one here even
with the weed competition
there's no wilting over here so that's
pretty striking so we were very happy
with that
so then we harvested it and let me see
after mowing and yield is not great but
it's about the same it is not
conventional plots so that's the first
one that I want to share with you
then the vet we tried that as well same
thing it's an indeterminate plant so we
wanted to cut it which we didn't do with
the Rye by the way with arriving just
waited until an tesis rolled it and
rolled it again after the soybeans came
over the edamame came up here we go you
can see it's all cut you can see those
how'd it's all cut okay this is actually
just a slide again but this is corn we
also did corn or this is actually meant
for the corner but do a color flower
later this is corn one more slide of
that corn after planting in the vets so
and we actually saw much better weed
control in the corn from the vets then
we saw in the Austrian field peace right
corn again observations very healthy
crop again less the wilting point was
you know of such a degree that it didn't
seem to suffer as much with a hot days
compared to the other but you can see
some weeds coming in though but the
canopy is closing up and then you see
these are all irrigated fields I will
mention that to you and then this is
close to harvest we had 300 back to
Diego which was more than our
conventional till our converse was
around 250 250 back to the acre so
that's what's a surprising number to us
that we saw that the
ears were fuller from that lot and that
thing that has something to do with you
know no water stress or something to
save for that it's hard for us to
compare one lots to the other especially
when you have bird damage these are 300
backs marketable ears so you know again
this is not research so but still it was
it was a good yield and we see these
yields consistently when we transplant
corn everybody always laughs when we
transplant corn but we find that we can
plan twice as much corn from happy acres
to be transplant because of the stand
that we grow the extra tender varieties
that really don't terminate very well
alright lastly the we also transplant a
cauliflower true veg and I just shown in
later slides I'm not going to go through
the whole sequence again and here
harvesting or that is in hoeing we dead
they did spend some time hauling they're
pulling out the big weeds now when we
went out there we had a Fisher by Yong
Hendrick crop and I class Martin so he
mentioned him before he came by to fire
him up and he went out there the first
thing that give me a shovel and it was
really great and educational for all of
us and I should have taken slides from
the conventional till plots because they
were powdered and then here we had some
really it's hard to see on this slide
but as wormholes everywhere you can see
the worms right here and it was a really
remarkable difference in soil structure
this soil wasn't blocky it was nice
round its texture to it where it was in
the cauliflower compared to the
cauliflower was conventional till here
it may be a better shot anyone familiar
with John Hendrick crop okay
so September 19th that crop stays really
clearly that the hoeing in here was
relatively minimal we did pull out some
big weeds let me see
September 21st I don't have yield
numbers but here I come again with some
anecdotal stuff regarding what the crew
was telling me as well
they loved harvesting cauliflower in
that section it didn't stink it was like
this is a very clean section the
cauliflower very high-quality and it was
really the the crop did not deteriorate
as fast in the field again we had less
tip burn in this cauliflower again a lot
to do with the water management I think
of the soil that we were working with so
well this really started an experiment
and saying like ok we have nothing to
lose I can make mistakes and I we were
really pleased and we're gonna continue
with with this experiment
what would we change I think we well we
already did mix in some triticale and
some rye you know vets to get a little
more biomass we'll see how that works
we hope that the triticale and rye will
not dominate the veg but you know it's
something that to see if we get better
weed control now the next step is for us
were sold on the system the next step
right now for us will be to see if we
can eliminate the the hand hoeing and
that will be kind of interesting I'll
keep it short because the ipi is waiting
all right some questions right how long
oh there's a date on there so I could
actually tell you
the earlier
well I think I normally when I do weed
control
I control weeds when I can't see them
all right that's the normal way of
thinking about weeds in this case and
that's where the little sting comes in
the weeds were about this big we had
some over at carpet so hence the
aggressive way of using it
how many weeks it was after I have to
look up the dates again if I go back
through the slides what you know the the
broccoli I could not have waited much
longer because I were to be driven with
my tractor tires on the plans so pretty
soon after that the canopy started to
close but I don't get the second part of
your question
yeah
yeah we would have to this is pretty
weird aground so it's it's not that in
in in the conventional tail would be
cultivated three times by that point
yes I think it's the ocean filled peace
compared to the veg it's really the veg
had better weed control than arson field
piece and then if you put the the
regular 4010 field piece it's even worse
we abandon it we did after rolling and
crimping we made a visual inspection and
we walk the field and we said like all
right it's this going to work if we see
weeds right now
then we're not going to do it I mean we
and and some of that has to do with a
fall seeding of austrian field piece is
that there were very little weeds under
the Archean field peace with the 4010
field piece and the bell beans weeds
germinated along with the field peas
that were planted in the spring so there
that's what's a big difference so if we
saw weed and I wonder if anyone wants to
try this I would say that the one thing
that we learned from this is that we do
all our weeding in the year before so
the year before when before we planted
the field piece at arson field piece and
the vets and the Rye we had a bear
fallow so this is by no means like we
didn't do till it's we did a lot of
toilets in the year before so we made
sure we did all our toilets and so our
aim is not to be no-till our aim is to
not disturb the soil and to provide
greater plant health now so it really
has and and not to have too much erosion
when the plants are still young
by the way none of these crops got any
fertilizer
except for boron not even the corn yes
yeah that's all you have to do yeah
so pretty much I we didn't have to apply
a lot of pressure this no-till drill
does have hydraulic pressure but it
didn't take a lot of pressure to have
the Coulter's run and and cut the cover
crop no they don't cut underneath they
that that is a that is a possibility
although I think well what are we saying
mad about that do you think that the
no-till drill what do you think the
action what'd you think it was the
second rolling that they're all the work
or is it the cutting
I
do it some of the cardigan or something
she's going that that way over it you
know you're not ready right now
then you're putting something in here
I think
a bit more I know but you're saying
about the games bills you know huffing
out there but it's not like they have
any points on
pretty soft yeah you can also drive over
it with the tractor under the wheel you
see a dime
Chartres you know I don't think that you
know that's a long long wait don't want
to turn fire here two dozen individual
gauge
and the one of the culture yes yeah yeah
well it just cut every seven have inches
so it's it's really these colors are
quite close but you might be right me
i'm we just thought what's the cutting
and maybe it's not the cutting but it
does work and it did killer because we
won we rolled some stuff and then we did
not like it's not dying what are we
gonna do so like let's run over at the
real drill i mean again
any more questions
they were I mean we actually we are
going to go to a smaller plan that's
only two weeks old these plans were I
believe 18 days yeah and they were they
were actually they're double planned in
a 72 we want to go back to a double plan
than a 162 because it just took too much
time to carry the traits to the
transplanter so that was one thing that
we have to buy another shoe for that
with the RJ planner but that was one
thing we want to correct we we thought
we needed a big plant we had not done
this before
we can definitely stick with 162 if you
plan every 14 inches to plants yes
the next crop we will try aside from
those ones we're gonna stick the dose
for now but we want to try a little bit
the transfer mulch and initially tried
it on potatoes and and and bring mulch
on after the potatoes our plant that's
enriched and then put them all on top of
them and then not to touch them because
we do have some wheat issues in the
potatoes but that's a whole different
system altogether well thank you very
much this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at cornell
edu